para dibujar el campo de pendientes para
la ecuación diferencial la derivada de
ye con respecto a x es igual a menos 2 x
tenemos esta ecuación diferencial
tenemos que poner pequeños segmentos de
rectas en algunos puntos del plano x y
completa las oraciones y bueno dicen en
el punto menos 1.1 tenemos que dibujar
un pequeño segmento de recta que tenga
una pendiente de espacio en blanco así
que como siempre pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes rellenar estos tres espacios en
blanco bien a los pequeños segmentos de
recta que estamos tratando de dibujar
para construir este campo dependientes
encuentran que su pendiente está basada
en la ecuación diferencial que tenemos
aquí está que puse de rojo entonces si
nos están diciendo que tenemos este
punto de aquí el punto donde x es igual
a menos 1 y es igual a 1 cuál es la
derivada de con respecto a x
en ese punto cuando x se toman esos
respectivos valores y bueno simplemente
va a ser sustituir los valores en esta
función así que para el primer caso
vamos a hacerlo me va a quedar que la
derivada de james con respecto a x está
que estoy buscando me va a ser igual
am y bueno observa que estamos en el
punto donde vale 1 ok y donde x vale
menos 1 así que me quedaría bien pero
que vale 1 entonces va a ser uno menos 2
por x pero x vale menos 1 entonces me
quedaría 2 x menos 1 y bueno esto va a
ser lo mismo que dos por menos su nombre
esto es lo mismo que menos 2 pero con
este signo menos me queda que todo esto
de kim es más dos
ok entonces 12 estrés por lo tanto esta
es la derivada de con respecto a x y xi
tenemos que dibujará un pequeño segmento
de recta este segmento debería de tener
una pendiente de 3 muy bien ahora en el
segundo punto obtengo que x vale 0 y
llévale 2 así que si queremos calcular
déjame ponerlo aquí la derivada de james
con respecto a x en ese punto
bueno va a ser lo mismo que bien pero en
este caso vale 2 me quedaría 2 - 2 x x
pero x vale 0 entonces serían 2 x 0 y
bueno esto es lo mismo que en 2 x 0 se
va y me queda simplemente 2 por lo tanto
tendríamos que dibujar un pequeño
segmento de recta que tenga una
pendiente de 2 de lugo y por último este
de aquí tengo la derivada de james con
respecto a x
en este punto bueno tenemos que en este
caso vale 3 me queda
3 - y 2 x x entonces serían 2 x 2 ahora
dos por dos es cuatro con este signo
negativo
esto me queda menos cuatro entonces tres
menos cuatro eso va a ser lo mismo que
menos uno entonces lo voy a poner aquí
menos uno de lujo ya tenemos estas tres
pendientes que estábamos buscando y esto
era justo lo que el ejercicio nos pide
que hagamos ahora si realmente tuvieras
que hacer el campo dependientes y
dibujarlo entonces se vería más o menos
así si dibujo por aquí uno de mis ejes
vamos a suponer que este es mi eje james
muy bien y por aquí voy a dibujar a mi
eje
tx ok déjame poner que este es mi eje
que por aquí estoy dibujando a mi eje x
y vamos a poner todos los respectivos
valores que tenemos el más grande en x
es el valor de 2
por lo tanto déjame decir que aquí
tenemos a 1 y aquí tenemos a 2 por aquí
tenemos a menos 1 y por aquí tenemos al
menos 2 muy bien ok y en james el más
grande es 3 entonces déjame ponerlo 123
ok por aquí voy a poner -1 y -2 así que
en el primer punto en este punto que
tengo aquí menos 1.1 déjame ver menos
1.1 estamos justo aquí vamos a tener una
pendiente de tres entonces se va a ver
más o menos sensible
tenemos una pendiente muy muy inclinada
algo más o menos así
ahora en el segundo punto déjame ponerlo
con este color en el punto 02 déjame ver
estamos aquí 12 aquí estamos
vamos a tener una pendiente de 2 así que
se ve inclinada pero no tan inclinada
algo más o menos así y por último en el
tercer punto déjame ponerlo con este
color en el punto 23 vamos a tener una
pendiente de menos 1 entonces 1 2 123
estamos como por aquí vamos a tener una
pendiente de menos 1 y justo esto lo
podríamos seguir haciendo con más y más
y más puntos de hecho si tuvieran una
computadora para hacerlo la computadora
lo que haría sería dibujarlo para muchos
más puntos y en cada uno de los puntos
dibujarían estos segmentos de recta para
indicar cuál es la derivada en ese punto
y así tener sentido del espacio de
solución para esta ecuación diferencial